le rhône est complètement sorti de son
lit et il a envahi les voies de chemin
de fer les zones industrielles et zones
d'habitation on a rarement montré un
déficit dévastateur il a roulé hier
jusqu'à 1400 mètres cubes par seconde
trois fois plus qu'une crue
normalisation neurones a débordé en
plusieurs endroits
hallassou spread à lui su sa chipie
s'est également rendue très nombreux
endroits les habitations sont inondées
les industries sont immondes et la
police cantonale a pris des clients de
faire mes tickets - l'autoroute
tout d'abord entre b et marqué ni puis
ensuite rentrer ville et reed d'euros
nets en colère on lui a imposé un
rapport de force
il en veut plus il a envie de liberté
avant les grands aménagements du 19e
siècle à partir de 1863 le rhône et ses
bras étaient les maîtres de la peine
les riverains s'adapter à leur dynamique
il construisait déjà des digues
depuis le moyen âge c'était pour
protéger leurs terrains de la plaine des
pâturages surtout et prêts privés des
jardins mais le fleuve était le maître
et ont lutté contre le fleuve sur ce
plan de 1803 entre stations et saxon
vous voyez c'est dick transversale elles
sont construites en bois et en pierre
par les hommes de saillon
malheureusement elle repousse l eau
contre l'autre rive vers saxons et vous
imaginez bien que les gens de saxon
n'appréciez pas trop ça c'était le
problème à l'époque on n'avait pas un
défi sans une vision d'ensemble pas de
coordination ni de cohésion alors ça
crée des conflits et conflits entre les
communes et conflit à cause du
on a décidé d'agir en 1803 déjà on a
décidé d'en finir avec la politique
menée depuis le moyen âge
depuis le moyen-âge en effet ce que
faisait les autorités c'était de dire
bon puisqu'il ya conflit
c'est aux tribunaux de gérer mais en
1803 les communes de 500 et de
martinique ont dit stop
elles ont écrit au conseil d'état elles
ont dit par pitié arrêtez d'envoyer la
question devant les tribunaux je vais
vous citer ce qu'elles ont dit
exactement
ayez la charité de ne pas envoyer cette
question aux tribunaux fleurs longue
interminable une winneuse formalités ne
peuvent rien contre le fleuve qui
dévastent ce pays
ça a pris du temps pour qu'on arrive à
faire un grand aménagement du fleuve ça
a pris 60 ans le temps que notre canton
se remettent des conflits internes et de
la défaite du thunder road
alors on a décidé de le corriger
on a fait la première correction du
rhône et je crois que c'est important
d'insister sur ce thème une correction
pourquoi parce qu'en france par exemple
aussi on a corrigé le fleuve mais on
parle d'aménagement du rhône on ne parle
pas de correction en valais on a décidé
de le corriger
on a construit des épis opposé
perpendiculaire à l'axé du fleuve et on
s'est dit le fleuve a collé entre ses
épis
au début ça a eu l'air d'être un succès
et puis petit à petit à la fin du 19e
siècle
déjà il y a eu des inondations et on
s'est rendu compte que
lit du fleuve c'est que ce fut toujours
plus ça devenait dangereux
on a dû faire une deuxième correction
cette fois ci quand elle était terminé
cette deuxième correction en 1960 le
fleuve était domestique et corsetée
entre des digues que l'on avait
surélevée et grand fort c'est le fleuve
autrefois dominant était dominé le
rapport était inversé la plaine aussi
avait changé on a assez mis la peine
entre 1920 et 1954
on a gagné dix mille hectares de
terrains cultivables
on s'est dit on a une raison on a bien
fait on a bien travaillé
et puis le climat nous donner raison
entre 1948 et 1987
il n'y a eu aucune crue importante le
fleuve est resté calme et tranquille bon
il y a bien vu des crues en 1987 et en
1993 mais seuls les spécialistes ont vu
qu'il y avait des fissures dans les
digues
le vrai tournant ça a été en devenir en
2000 1100 hectares de plaines des pays
nantais 85% des communes du canton ont
été touchés des milliers de personnes
évacuées et savait 650 millions de
dégâts
là on s'est rendu compte que l'illusion
d'un fleuve domestique et c'était
terminé
la méthode que l'on avait appliqué
depuis la fin des années 60
c'est à dire creusée le fleuve avec des
gras vial et renforcer les digues au
besoin cette méthode ne fonctionnait
plus il fallait faire quelque chose
on a décidé qu'il fallait faire une
troisième correction
on dit jamais deux sans trois mètres la
troisième sera la bonne le chalet que
vous voyez que vous voyez ici sur cette
image représentait au labyrinthe
aventure d'evionnaz le valais en octobre
2000 est face à un nouveau défi
il n'est pas le seul en france aussi il
ya eu de terribles inondations à avignon
par exemple en décembre 2003 en france
aussi les collectivités publiques sont
obligés de réagir
elles ont créé le plan rhône cette
nouvelle stratégie marque une rupture
on se rend compte que la technique ne
répond pas à tous les besoins que la
technique ne permet pas d'assurer une
protection absolue on admet que la seule
solution c'est de redonner des espaces
de liberté aux fleurs en valais aussi
les ingénieurs ont fait le même constat
qu'en france sur ces deux illustrations
les lignes rouges représentent le niveau
d'eau lors d'une crue semblable à
hestrus d'octobre 2000 vous voyez que
dans quelques années ce niveau d'eau
sera clairement abc c'est parce que l'on
va faire des élargissements à certains
enfants
la taille des élargissements sera en
général de 50% la taille actuelle ce qui
permet d'évacuer 50% donnez-lui de débit
supplémentaire dans les zones on ne peut
pas élargir comme dans les villes par
exemple comme à sion on va abaisser le
lit du fleuve et dans d'autres endroits
on va donner encore plus d espace au
rhône le tracé du lit sera plus naturel
la faune et la flore courant se
diversifier on pourra créer des
activités de loisirs et de détente
imaginez la mobilité douce sera
privilégiée et surtout la population
pourra se réapproprier le rhône qui
deviendra certainement un acteur
touristes
important dans la plaine l'eau et les
fleuves passionne tous les citoyens du
monde
j'ai pu le remarquer cet hiver quand
j'ai fait découvrir notre fleuve un
photographe trop enlevée il a pris cette
photo a ship is parce qu'il
s'intéressait à la face cachée de l'eau
et cette photo c'est celle de l' usine
hydroélectrique de ship is une très
ancienne usine qui date du début du 20e
siècle et qui utilise les eaux du fleuve
pour faire de l'électricité
cette photographie aujourd'hui est
exposée au rwanda elle témoigne du
regard d'un artiste sur le rhône et
surtout elle nous interroge
est ce que nous avons envie de créer une
collaboration avec le fleuve demandez
vous est ce que j'aimerais vivre en
harmonie avec le rhône merci